un seul titre à cette édition le paris
dakar est en deuil
le paris dakar s'est également
l'actualité régionale à plus d'un titre
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir le paris dakar doit continuer
telle était la volonté de thierry sabine
s'il lui arrivait un accident thierry
sabine est mort le paris dakar continue
les concurrents seront ce soir à bamako
au terme de la plus longue étape
vous savez cet accident d'hélicoptère
est survenu hier soir non loin de gourma
au mali et a coûté la vie non seulement
à thierry sabine mais également à daniel
balavoine au pilote de cet hélicoptère
et au technicien radio également à notre
consoeur du journal du dimanche
nathalie audin le récit de cet accident
avec jérôme prenne fin c'est mardi soir
aux environs de 19 heures que s'est
produit l'accident l'hélicoptère de
thierry sabine voler à très basse
altitude il suivait une voiture du ravi
la visibilité était mauvaise
la nuit tombée un fort vent de sable
soufflait l'appareil a percuté une dune
et s'est immédiatement disloqué
l'un des concurrents du rallye qui a été
témoin de l'accident a expliqué qu'il
avait vu les feux l'hélicoptère puis
entendu un grand bruit
après cet arrêté il a découvert les
débris de l'appareil et les cinq corps
disloqué thierry sabine daniel balavoine
et les trois personnes qui les
accompagnaient comme il le faisait
régulièrement avait repris les airs
quelques instants auparavant pour
rechercher des concurrents égaré après
une étape particulièrement difficile et
pour trouver un bivouac pour accueillir
la caravane et les corps des victimes je
viens de l'apprendre seront rapatriés
demain à paris je vous le disais en ce
début de journal là le rallye paris
dakar continue à savoir sous quelle
forme sera s'il sous forme de
compétition ou bien en constituant un
convoi qui regrouperait l'ensemble de la
caravane jusqu'à dakar les concurrents
le décideront eux mêmes ce soir à leur
arrivée à bamako